good afternoon everyone my name is da da
da da I will be briefly summarizing the
poster systems genetics of
hepatocellular carcinoma challenges
talking about the hcc system from
different perspectives and challenges so
let me start with the genetical aspect
factors such as alcohol
consumption/smoking infections such as
hepatitis B and C viruses and other
genetic factors results in constitutive
cytokine expression and recruitment of
immune cells leading to inflammatory
environment this further generates
oxidative stress by releasing reactive
oxygen species and nitric oxide leading
to gene mutation and polymer for
polymorphism so now what are the
challenges here the first being genetic
variability prone to disease
environmental factors such as age race
etc many SNP's are in the susceptibility
low side way making it difficult to
prioritize variants contributing to the
disease so have we considered genetic
testing or using fausto proteomic essays
to classify patients based on different
pathway activation signal next the
epigenetics epigenetic mechanisms
include RNA editing DNA methylation
histone modifications etc while the
global hypomethylation cause disturbance
in the methylated regions of the genome
leading to the genome and chromosomal
instability the promoter
hypermethylation influences mainly tumor
suppressor genes further moving to
histone modification which includes
histone methylation as tightly
phosphorylation etc among these histone
methylation sakes attention as it leads
to tumor suppressor gene silencing now
why epigenetics is explored now mainly
owing to its reversible nature which can
be used as therapeutic targets speaking
of challenges well it would be
reactivation of epigenetically silenced
tumor suppressor genes can we target
epigenetic events in a non specified way
rather than in a specified manner
keeping the challenges in mind let me
move on to the non-coding RNAs these
include mi RNAs and long non-coding RNAs
certain mi rnase act as oncogenes by
affecting biological process by others
act as tumor suppressor genes affecting
biological processes as well
transfecting mi RNA mimicking molecules
using nanoparticles have been shown to
be highly specific to target ACC cells
challenges here are the expression
profile of mi RNA in hbv patients
differs from that of HCV patient so how
do we actually come up with a common
platform in spite of these differences
how to better understand the role of
circulating mi RNA in tumor
microenvironment and tumor immune
evasion what other ways to deliver mi
RNA to the HCC cells can be found having
said that now let's move on to long
non-coding RNAs they can be used as
biomarkers owing to their detection in
the body fluids such as urine and plasma
similar to circulating mi RNAs and so
highly cell and tissue specific
expression as it is being explored
recently what next how better can be
characterized long non-coding RNAs in
terms of structure and functions in
order to be devised better strategies
what model or approach can be used to
define the functional areas of long
non-coding RNA
as the single sequence is not possible
to predict one the third aspect is the
therapeutics so it includes generalized
treatments which deals with patience and
taught ecstatic and conditions and they
involve early stage treatments
intermediate stage and advanced rates
treatments the other includes the modern
treatment which has an area of drugs
assigned to regulate definitive systemic
pathway regulation which has the use of
small molecule antibodies such as
definitive and monoclonal antibodies
such as trust those who made to target
molecules modern treatments also include
with gene therapy such as immune gene
therapy anti-angiogenic therapy suicide
gene therapy etc and various other
combination therapies the challenges
although the bclc the Barcelona clinic
liver cancer stating system is
recommended yet there is still a need to
establish a standard for classification
of the stages or to come to a consensus
into its biological heterogeneity and
the nature of each patient what other
challenges here I would stress on the
need for comparative genomic analysis
between human HCC's and model organisms
to validate novel oncogenes and tumor
suppressor genes to really narrow down
studies to capture the key features such
as genomic instability and fibrotic
micro environment in accelerating the
testing of agents prior to moving to
clinical trials there is a need to fully
assess the susceptible gentech element
in different population studies a higher
need to use the high-resolution
approaches or to come up with one for
detailed genome analysis to clearly
annotate samples and then a requirement
of molecular targeted therapeutic
options based on etiology and the
activation of different pathways in
depth
patience which may lead to more
personalized treatments last but not the
least understanding cancer or HCC from
the above-mentioned events may help us
to find avenues to combat cancer I would
like to conclude by thanking the members
from bio clues and dr. sylvia from i pan
for the poster contribution and lab
roots for organizing this wonderful
conference thank you and have a great
day